check out this story from timcast.com
U.S drone a complete loss after being
hit by a Russian jet these aggressive
actions by Russian air crew are
dangerous said U.S European command
that's basically the story oh it's
written by you why don't you tell us
Santa Clara what happened he's so
nervous when he does like popcorn
meeting in school
um so there were two Russian su-27
fighter jets flying uh above in
international airspace above the uh
Black Sea as was an mq aircraft which is
a drone I know a ton about the military
I'm an expert here and basically uh one
of the Jets uh clipped the propeller and
it made it so the Drone was inoperable a
crashed they were also saying that the
the planes were like throwing fuel at
the Drone and the U.S European command
and our uh defense department were like
this is unprofessional this is dangerous
how could Russia act this way in
response Russia is you know Russia has
complained several times that it does
not appreciate that the US and the
United Kingdom have expanded their
surveillance operations especially in
international especially around the
Crimean Peninsula and so as it turns out
they aren't going to just roll over and
let drones photograph whatever's going
on there and uh it's hard to say because
Russia is uh is saying you know well
we're the ones who are open to the the
peace talks that the Chinese have
proposed but it's it's uh ma it's
Ukraine that won't participate you know
it's double-edged all around but I think
this is one of those moments that if the
U.S wants to escalate they will say Well
they're just getting out of control
these unprofessional Russian military
planes trying to attack us you know I
actually got a tip on some of the
cockpit crosstalk from the Russian
pilots and as they were rolling up on
the reaper they're playing highway to
the danger zone watching Top Gun they
were watching and they was going to try
and go upside down and peed on the Drone
right to communicate right like they
were doing yeah yeah and then he got
caught in the jet wash that's what it
was right it was see it was all One Big
Mess
or is it basically Russia being like we
want these U.S surveillance drones out
of our war I mean look at
considering Russia is a nuclear-armed
you know what used to be a superpower
but they have nuclear weapons uh the I
personally have no problem with the
United States being in international
waters monitoring
I have no issue with that like the US is
is well within their rights to be in
international waters monitoring a
conflict that could have you know Global
consequences except Russia knows that
the U.S is not just monitoring they're
actively providing the intelligence to
the United States
doesn't mean anything I don't think they
were I think this was if if my neighbor
is flinging mud at me and I'm flinging
mud back and then you're on the street
telling the other guy like how to
respond to me and how and you're
stopping behind that I'm like you are
helping the guy who's fighting me I
don't care where you are it does like I
said it's it's I don't see any problem
with the United States saying look we're
going to monitor this situation because
of the fact that they have nuclear
weapons right except for the Russians
they're like they're not just monitoring
it they're providing intelligence to
Ukraine they are actively engaging in
the more Russians the the United States
is actually sending tanks yes they're
not worried about a drone monitoring
they're worried about actual materials
literally just took out one of our
drones likely because they're upset that
we're spying on I think it was more
Robin is racing and it got out of
control I don't think they were trying
to take the Drone I think that was
probably enough they were going to take
it out I imagine they would have shot
because you don't suppose you don't take
that chance shooting it is an act of War
whoopsie we bumped into it is uh call
our Bluff this is the only time one of
these interactions has resulted in a
crash so there have been other instances
where fighter jets have gone up to
interact with the drones is the only one
that has uh knocked out a US drone
here's the thing Vlad has no doubt in
his mind whatsoever that we are at war
with him all right he's got a he's got a
shooting war with the ukrainians and
zelenskies he gets four wise I give him
four wise but Vlad knows that we are not
just a proxy in this we are actively
fighting him so it's a U.S Russia war
with Ukraine doing the fighting right
now not even as Americans on the ground
American veterans volunteered and then
armed by the Americans that makes no
sense you know the problem with Malcolm
Nance going over there was everything he
ate so much that the rest of the
Ukrainian troops couldn't help Finance
he's such a poser tool he's an
embarrassment I don't disagree that the
U.S you know it's not unreasonable and
for moderate I just don't think it's
unreasonable for it for Russia to try
and prevent it right like acting like
this is like some Act of Russian
aggression when actually it's Russian
defense like that seems sort of you know
it's like the American Media wants the
public to think Russia is suddenly
getting aggressive in a way that it
shouldn't yeah I mean the the United
States the general population in the U.S
is extremely ignorant about the whole
Ukraine war they don't no one even
thinks about any anything that happened
in 2014 they don't think about anything
prior to when Russia invaded you know
last year and I I understand that and
there's a lot of people that are
anti-war that are like yo the U.S
shouldn't even be looking over there
because it could inflames things I
understand there are people like that
I'm just in my opinion because of the
stakes because of the possibility of
nuclear war I don't have a problem with
the United States monitoring the
situation I don't have the problem I
don't have a problem with the uh if
we're not in Ukrainian airspace if we're
in international waters I don't have an
issue with it but we're not like Tim
said we're not just doing that and the
thing is there is a goal now to defeat
Putin right now all the way but but
that's that's zelenski's goal he wants
him out of Crimea and that is the goal
of far too many people in the U.S
national security apparatus let me let
me ask you Phil if if the U.S operated
you know artillery from across the
Polish border into Ukraine to take out
Russian targets would Russia be like
well you know they're in Poland since
operating operating artillery is not
intelligence is 100 times more important
than one artillery it's still not you
can't say oh any unite any you can there
is no at all there is no precedent for
uh a state to say you cannot fly or if
you fly in international waters we're
going to take that as an act of
aggression that is there is no precedent
like that and that doesn't stand up to
to anybody's Assumption of what is a
reasonable uh active
throne and you provide targeting
information to people on the ground
you don't know the Drone what's it doing
that
I'm sure that's what I don't know that
it's targeting it's a reasonable or
something are you serious you can you
that pretty you don't know that the
Drone is is running targeting
information
the U.S provided information on the
Russians to the ukrainians to blow up I
wonder how craniums are not dropping J
damn right there's no there's no drones
lazing Targets in Ukraine for for
there's no jtac they don't have an
advanced Warf that's not it's fighting
how did the US get the Intel the intel
on the location of the black ship flag
the Black Sea flagship
how did they get that Intel the one that
was in the sea in the Black Sea there
was a the Russian I imagine from from
satellites so not not the Drone that's
literally flying over the Black Sea I I
don't know where I don't know what the
sword is what they're trying to be doing
I don't know what the sorties they're
running I don't know what this what the
strategy is I don't have I don't have
insight into the the people that are
actually running the plans to say that
just a drone a drone could be they could
be taking they could be monitoring with
video they could be monitoring ship
movements there's all kinds of things
that are totally legitimate and totally
not not escalation or or acting in the
uh in the war that a drone could be
doing just monitoring the US this is a
fact gave the intelligence to the
ukrainians to blow up the Black Sea
Flagship of the Russian Navy
now Russia could be sitting there going
well it could have been satellite or it
could be that thing flying around in
circles above the Black Sea Let's ignore
it completely even if it's a saddle is
it not still the same thing if you give
targeting information to someone who
uses it to destroy a piece of military
equipment you are an active participant
in this there's no listen there's not
Material support there's not a question
of whether or not the United States is
lending material support everybody
believes that the United States blew up
the then why are you shocked that Russia
would clip or take out an American drone
who's shocked I'm just saying that the
US has every right to be there
they're in international waters so it's
not an S not an aggressive act to be in
Internet to be flying a drone in
international waters is not an act of
aggression by the United States that's
all that's it and I I agree with you
because I don't want that to become a
standard at some level we do have
freedom of maneuver and navigation
anywhere we want international waters is
international law any military can can
totally operate in any military has
leads
any military has legal authority to
operate in the National Water when law
is meaningless in war completely mean
it's like I find the idea of war crimes
laughable like somebody who wants to win
a war is going to win a war and they
don't care what you think the crime is
so if uh let's say we're at war with
Japan and they bomb Pearl Harbor and
then all of a sudden Japanese Fighters
are buzzing our our our
buzzing Hawaii again we're gonna be like
well hold on guys they have every right
to fly around international waters we're
not going to strike them we blow them up
two seconds we don't care what they're
doing we're not in a declared war with
Russia
since when World War I said we're not
we're not in we're not in a in a right
now the United States was not in a
fighting war with Russia yes we are
we didn't declare war therefore we're
not at War it's like okay well there's
U.S Special Forces U.S Personnel U.S
tanks U.S training U.S intelligence and
the Russians have outright declared
we're at war with them thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time